yeah when was the last time you washed
your hands did you know that nearly 80%
of infectious diseases are spread by
contacting things around you we touch
money and door handles we share pens to
sign documents in banks and whatnot home
and we love shaking hands and that's
just gross it's not surprising that
washing your hands with soap is the
number one preventative measure against
viruses but what if you ignored your
hand hygiene for say a year how many
different germs would make your palms
their home and how can you alone cause a
worldwide economic crisis this is what
if and here's what would happen if you
didn't wash your hands for a year
[Music]
everyone knows we have to wash our hands
with soap but the reality is most of us
are either doing it wrong or aren't
doing it at all let me show you what
happens when you grow your hand bacteria
in petri dishes this squeaky clean
sample is after a full 20 second hand
wash with soap this sample has the
bacteria that's left when you just rinse
your hands with water and this one shows
how much bacteria lives on your hands
when you don't wash them now are you
ready for some gross stats the Centers
for Disease Control and Prevention or
CDC found that 69% of men and 35% of
women don't wash their hands after using
a public bathroom and 93 percent of
people don't wash their hands after
coughing or sneezing
[Music]
okay I'm gonna wash my hands right now
where were we
ah not washing your hands for a year
I hope our research team didn't test
this one on themselves all right here
are some ground rules let's assume that
hypothetically your hands didn't touch
soap or hand sanitizer for 12 months you
could still swim and shower or get your
hands wet in the rain but you didn't
wash them how soon will you become a
walking bacterial stick unfortunately I
can't give you an exact timeline here it
depends on too many factors like the
types of germs and how many people you
come in contact with and it looks like
we didn't sacrifice our researchers for
that purpose the only certainty is that
you would get sick when well soon enough
in the short term your hands would start
looking aesthetically displeasing they'd
be covered in dirt and grease and a
plethora of unseen bacteria people would
stop shaking your hands and I wouldn't
even give you an elbow bump but the
unpleasant look of your hands would be
the least of your problems according to
research from the University of Colorado
our hands carry some 3,200 bacteria from
150 different species every time you
used the toilet the number of germs on
your fingertips would double that has
something to do with the fact that germs
can spray up to two meters in the air
when you flush you transfer all those
bacteria to your food and drinks and
that would be making you repeatedly sick
you'd be having 30% more diarrhea
related illnesses and 20% more
respiratory infections like flu your
doctor would keep prescribing
antibiotics eventually the bacteria on
your hands would develop resistance to
those meds and
would stop helping you if that's not bad
enough you'd make others sick as well
and if everyone got sick they'd have to
take time off work and lock themselves
at home when people stay home and don't
get out to restaurants or shopping malls
the economy takes a nosedive if a
pandemic spreads all over the world the
economic slowdown could cost trillions
of dollars bottom line not washing your
hands for a year
kissing something you want to try but if
you do make sure to practice social
distancing so you don't come in contact
with too many people and cause another
pandemic washing hands helps save lives
it's the best method for removing hand
bacteria and stopping the spread of
viruses here's how to do it right wet
your hands with clean water turn off the
tap and apply soap keep lathering your
hands for at least 20 seconds you can
hum a verse of your favorite song twice
or just watch this video from this point
to the end make sure to watch the
between your fingers under your nails
and to back your hands rinse your hands
with water and dry them with a clean
towel do it regularly and stay safe next
time you want to do something crazy try
going with no shower for a month but
that's a story for another what if
okay you can start rinsing your hands
now